bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui luttent contre le
confinement des esprits
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la pénurie de matières
premières bourges où est elle bonjour
olivier bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de ses
caches c'est la nouvelle menace qui pèse
sur l'industrie une pénurie de matières
premières comment est ce possible
qu'elles sont elles les filières
touchées et quelles conséquences pour
les entreprises
cette crise est elle amenée à durer
voici à les questions auxquelles on
tentera de répondre dans cette émission
et puis on en parlera en deuxième partie
avec un nicolas meilhan consultant en
stratégie est spécialisée sur les
secteurs du transport et de l'énergie
est membre d econoclaste c'est le
premier constat les prix flambent plus
80% pour les semi-conducteurs composants
indispensables à la fabrication de
matériel informatique + 50 % pour le
bois de construction + 115 % pour le pvc
à l'heure où l'on parle
pourquoi le prix ados ces matériaux qui
font intégralement partie de notre vie
quotidienne sont ils en train de
s'envoler éléments de réponse avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine bassesse
[Musique]
cela pourrait être un coup de plus porté
à l'industrie déjà lourdement frappée
par la crise
une pénurie de matières premières selon
la fédération française du bâtiment et
la fédération des industries mécaniques
en maintenant les prix ont bondi jusqu'à
40% pour le letton l'aluminium le bronze
l'acier aurait pris lui 100% six mois
l'explication serait toute simple la
bonne v loi de l'offre et de la demande
alors que les producteurs des matières
en question avait posé le pied sur le
frein avec la pandémie la reprise
économique dans certains pays et
notamment la chine a été plus importante
que prévu du coût trop de demandes pas
assez d'offres et les prix augmentent
cqfd
tout cela engendre dont des chaînes de
production à l'arrêt et du chômage
partiel pour certaines usines du retard
sur les livraisons
le secteur du btp essentiels qui fait
travailler près de 1.5 millions de
personnes en france était déjà touché
fortement par le cos vide avec un volume
d'activité en chute de 15% et pourraient
donc subir une deuxième crise qui
porterait un sérieux coup à la reprise
économique globale
espérée en 2021
olivier outre la loi de l'offre et de la
demande on imagine que d'autres
paramètres viennent expliquer non
seulement cette flambée des prix mais
aussi cette menace de pénurie qui
commence à se faire sentir dans certains
secteurs
oui alors attention la pénurie l est pas
elle n'est pas pour aujourd'hui elle est
même pas pour demain
vous avez un phénomène qui est le
phénomène qui a fait monter tous les
actifs et qui ne sont pas forcément des
actifs industriels et des métaux ou
autre qui est le l'inondation par les
banques centrales de monnaie et cette
inondation par les banques centrales de
monnaie a fait tout simplement grimper
les prix des matières premières qui sont
je vous le rappelle pour la plupart
financiarisé donc vous avez des contrats
futures dessus qui font que alors soit
disant au départ c'était pour ce pour
que les uns les industriels puissent se
couvrir en fait c'est c'est de la pure
spéculation
et ça a fait monter pas mal les les
matières premières et toutes les
matières premières aujourd'hui
figurez-vous on a on a pas on ne
consomme pas plus de sucre et le sucre a
monté de 70% donc le cours du sucre a
monté de 70% donc on n'est pas dans un
on est pas dans une inflation se dirait
uniquement d'offre et demande alors
c'est vrai qu'il ya une demande qui est
un petit peu supérieure quand les les
pays redémarre mais on est loin d'avoir
un problème de 2
de d'offres par rapport à cette demande
je vous rappelle que le taux
d'utilisation des capacités est très bas
on est à 70 %
vous avez beaucoup d'entreprises qui ne
sont pas mortes avec les aides de l'état
et qui donc ont continué à à produire et
donc vous êtes le l'inflation vous savez
c'est un phénomène qui est de décalage
entre l'adaptation de l'offre par
rapport à une demande qui tout d'un coup
flambent
or aujourd'hui on n'a pas de problème
d'adaptation de l'offre puisque les
outils de production sont là et ils ont
été sous utilisé pendant des lustres et
donc qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas parce
qu'il ya une petite reprise dans
certains pays que il faut se tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé et croire que à cause
de ça on va être en pénurie surtout les
sur toutes les matières premières merci
olivier tout de suite la deuxième partie
cette émission et pour évoquer cette
tension sur les matières premières nous
accueillons cette semaine nicolas
meilhan bonjour monsieur vous êtes
consultant en stratégie spécialisé sur
les secteurs du transport et de
l'énergie membres d econoclaste merci à
vous d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
bienvenue dans ces caches
bonjour alors nicolas meilhan en
première partie olivier nous expliquer
qu'on ne pouvait pas parler de pénurie
vous quel est votre avis alors il est
clairement pas de pénurie a parlé à
court terme de sur les matières
premières les matières premières vers
différents facteurs qui vont impacter
leurs prix comme olivier la vie vous
avez effectivement les politiques
monétaires ça va jouer un rôle très
important notamment après la crise
financière des subprimes sur les prix du
pétrole on avait eu quatre années à plus
de 110 dollars le baril par exemple vous
avez quand même à court terme un
équilibre dynamique entre l'offre et la
demande qui fait qu'avec le kobe de 19
les prix des matières premières se sont
d'abord effondrée c'était le cas sur le
pétrole et que l'on à une lente reprise
notamment parce qu'il ya un pays qui est
moins touchée que les autres qui est le
seul pays qui a fait de la croissance
économique
officiellement en 2001 qui est la chine
et donc c'est petit décalage entre une
demande qui augmente en chine et
l'ajustement de l'offre qu'ils offrent
effectivement les capacités sont là mais
il ya aussi un problème de recrutement
recrutement des personnes qui n'ont pas
pu travailler qui ont pu parfois aller
essayer de faire d'autre d'autres
métiers et c'était justement fait que
vous avez un os à court terme des
matières premières vous avez un
troisième facteur aussi qui est le
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole qui
avaient joué sur le depuis la décennie
2010 qui est un sous jacent puisque
celle utilisée pour toute la fabrication
et le transport de ces matières est donc
le prix du pétrole qui était à 20 $ il
ya six mois et qui aujourd'hui et ont
entre 60 et 70 dollars
un impact aussi sur ce prix là olivier
est ce que cette tension qu'on observe
sur les matières premières elle est
inédite et ce qu'on a par exemple pu
observer ce genre d'événement au cours
des vingt dernières années pourquoi
aujourd'hui on parle de menace de
pénurie et on tire un peu tous les
sonnettes d'alarmé non le sait c'est un
phénomène qui n'a rien de nouveau
vous aviez exactement le même phénomène
sur la la la le début 2000 jusqu'en 2006
2007 vous aviez une une assez forte
tension sur beaucoup de matières
premières mais là qui était en grande
partie due à la hausse de l'activité ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui si vous
voulez on est on est très en dessous de
dunes d'une activité normale dans quasi
tous les pays et même d'ailleurs la
chine qui a repris on est très très en
dessous de d'une activité normale donc
qu'on est loin d'avoir une tension part
je dirais par la demande et
aimez vous en avez eu dans le passé à de
multiples reprises nicolas noté quand
vous avez eu des bébés cours sur autour
de 110 dollars le baril là vous aviez
une réelle tension sur le sur le prix du
pétrole
mais là aussi elles étaient du ces il y
avait de multiples facteurs d'abord il y
avait une reprise économique après le
krach de après la récession de 2008
et puis vous aviez surtout aussi
l'action des banques centrales qui
donnait de l'argent pour pour aller
jouer
or vous avez à partir du moment où vous
avez une matière première et
financiarisée à partir du moment où vous
avez d'ailleurs un actif qui et
financiarisée comme l'immobilier par
exemple eh bien vous avez quand on vous
donne de l'argent gratuitement pendant
un moment
vous aurez d'abord une flambée des
actions ensuite vous savez plus très
bien quoi faire donc vous allez sur les
obligations suite vous allez sur les
métaux ensuite vous allez sur les autres
actifs parce que il faut que vous
trouviez ou déverser tout cet argent et
donc vous allez aussi sur les matières
premières
vous avez vu qu'en plus on se réjouit
sans arrêt de mettre des contrats sur
tout et n'importe quoi le dernier
contrat en date c'est sur l'eau donc ne
doutais pas que vous aurez à un moment
ou à un autre une flambée de l'eau et ça
pourra être inquiétante au même prix que
les matières premières au même prix que
les matières premières alimentaires qui
flambent et qui peuvent dans ce cas-là
créer des famines dans certains pays
mais si on marque une courte pause on se
retrouve dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine ce
risque de pénurie sur les matières
premières et pour en parler nous sommes
en liaison avec l nicolas meilhan
consultant en stratégie spécialisé sur
les secteurs du transport et de
l'énergie est membre d econoclaste alors
certains secteurs sont tout de même un
petit peu touché l'automobile
l'agroalimentaire le bâtiment
l'électronique est la métallurgie et la
chimie
elle est le représentant de six filières
ont participé à une réunion le 14 avril
dernier avec la ministre chargé de
l'industrie cette dernière a prévenu le
déblocage des matières premières ne se
fera pas avant cet été ou à la fin du
second semestre voire la fin de l'année
pour les semi-conducteurs autrement dit
la crise un petit peu dur et est ce que
vous êtes d'accord nicolas n'ayant pas
de perspectives de retour à la normale
au minimum avant l'été bah vous allez
avoir vos cette tension elle existe il
ya un événement qui s'est passé en 2011
ce qui s'appelle fukushima on a eu aussi
un problème sur les semi conducteurs
c'est aussi lié en partie au fait qu'on
est sur des chaînes de valeur globale et
donc des kills à bloc dans un endroit
ces impacts tout le reste de la chaîne
ça il faut pas non plus oublier dans des
chaînes de valeur très mondialisé vous
avez un petit jeu de dominos qui se
répercute sur tous les éléments de la
chaîne il ya un événement dont on n'a
pas parlé qui est quand même aussi qu'au
delà de la reprise de l'économie que la
transition énergétique va être beaucoup
plus consommatrices d'ailleurs c'est
assez surprenant mais beaucoup plus
consommatrice de matières premières ça
compte ça utilise beaucoup plus de
matière première de fabriquer les
éoliennes de cuivre de béton faire que
de fabriquer une centrale au gaz une
centrale nucléaire ça consomme beaucoup
plus de matière première de fabriquer
une voiture électrique que de fabriquer
une voiture qui fonctionne avec du
pétrole
donc si même à court terme on n'a pas de
réellement on doit avoir un réajustement
de l'offre par rapport à la demande qui
se fera dans les prochains mois mais il
ya un réel risque par contre de pénurie
sur certaines matières premières à moyen
terme je prends l'exemple du pétrole le
maximum de l'extraction du pétrole a été
passé en novembre 2018
il n'est pas il n'est pas certain que ce
niveau passé
2018 puisse être atteint à nouveau dans
les prochaines années sera peut-être
était le maximum d'extraction du pétrole
pour l'histoire de l'humanité pour la
simple et bonne raison que notamment le
pétrole de roche-mère aux états unis la
reprise va être beaucoup plus lente
qu'anticipé par les analystes
on a d'autres matières qui vont être
concernés toutes celles qui rentrent
dans la composition des batteries des
voitures électriques comme le nickel
comme le lithium comme le cobalt qui
nécessitent des investissements sur
plusieurs années pour s'assurer
effectivement que les capacités suivent
la demande et donc là effectivement
entre 2025 et 2030 pourraient commencer
à apparaître si nous n'avions s'ils sont
pas suffisamment et une augmentation
mois sont pas suffisamment l'offre
certaines contraintes sur ces matériaux
là est donc là il ya un vrai travail qui
n'est pas fait sur la transition
énergétique
c'est que la meilleure façon d'éviter
ces contraintes c'est d'en consommer le
moins possible
donc ce qu'on appelle de la sobriété de
faire des voitures plus légères de faire
des batteries plus petites est
aujourd'hui malheureusement la
transition énergétique est pas très loin
d'être une véritable fête news qui
consiste à mettre un petit coup de
peinture verte sur un maximum d'objets y
compris les avions mais malheureusement
on n'est pas du tout en train de
résoudre des problèmes mais plutôt d'en
créer
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait justement
pour pour solutionner cette situation
est ce qu on pourrait par exemple se
tourner vers la chimie du végétal c'est
ce que propose françois monnet président
de l'association chimie du végétal pour
lui il est indispensable est d'accélérer
développement de la chimie du végétal
qui valorise le co2 capturé par les
plantes et évite l extrait sur
l'extraction pardon de ressources
fossiles il s'agit de produits
biosourcés issus du monde végétal est
déjà utilisé par de nombreux industriels
pour fabriquer les des produits de notre
quotidien pour information cette filière
en france représente déjà plus de 10
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et 165 mille emplois directs et
indirects et c'est aussi l'une des 10
technologies privilégiée dans france
relance le plan de sauvetage français de
l'économie ce serait une solution viable
ça olivier par exemple écouter alors là
moi je suis pas un scientifique donc je
peux pas vous dire si c'est une solution
viable
tout ce que je sais c'est que on le voit
d'ailleurs alors c'est pour un autre
c'est pour une autre chose mais on le
voit sur le le bioéthanol par exemple ou
vous risquez de faire la même chose que
ce que vous faites sur le pétrole mais
sur le blé est sûre
et sur dd des plantes qui servent à
faire ce bio éthanol donc on tourne on
comme le dit nicolas il faudrait
peut-être se poser d'autres questions ou
en tout cas de se les poser autrement
plutôt que de foncer dans une direction
qui l'a et le le tout électrique et sans
se préoccuper de tout ce qu'il ya autour
et nous annoncer ça comme la solution
idéale
alors que on est en train de voir que ça
mais c'est loin d'être la solution
idéale
donc je pense qu'il y aura de multiples
solutions à trouver peut-être que c'est
une piste je n'y connais rien je vous le
dis donc peut-être que c'en est une
maintenant arrêtons aussi de deux de
foncer tête baissée à chaque fois sur
une filière sans se préoccuper du reste
et et
on s'apercevra probablement dans
quelques années
le tout électrique n'était pas forcément
la solution la meilleure
alors là oui juste pour revenir sur le
bio végétal ce qu'on me propose à
invoquer au moyen-âge n'y a pas de
problème mais moyen-âge ont été moins
nombreux et ont consommé moins on
s'extrait du végétal grâce au pétrole et
aux matières premières
donc on peut y retourner mais ça prend
beaucoup de place et ont peu fait
consommer beaucoup moins avec donc
peut-être que ça peut jouer un rôle il
ya beaucoup de filières et de
technologies qui peuvent jouer un rôle
on aura besoin de tout le monde
mais la priorité c'est de parler du
besoin de quoi avons nous besoin et ce
débat là est inexistant alors on l'a
évoqué en de nombreux secteurs sont
touchés par ce manque de matières
premières exemple avec l'automobile
selon nos confrères de france télé
l'usiné psa sochaux a stoppé sa
production de peugeot 308 pendant trois
semaines résultat est 6000 voitures
n'ont pu sortir de l' usine comme prévu
chez autre exemple avec les fabricants
de peinture qui manquent de pigments et
des additifs conséquences quelques
références de peinture manquait à
l'appel
elle chez les distributeurs des exemples
comme ceux là on en trouve beaucoup dans
l'actualité aujourd'hui olivier est ce
que c'est un coup d'arrêt ont le pouvoir
d'un pacte est sérieusement la reprise
économique espérée
il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont
impacter la reprise économique espérée
par monsieur bruno le maire plus que le
manque de pigments faut être sérieux et
et surtout une reprise qui pour
l'instant n'existe pas vous le rappelle
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de reprise
en france
mais pardon est ce que cette pénurie à
de matières premières elle ferait elle
fragilise encore plus les entreprises
mais pour l'instant ils viennent pas
besoin de matières premières elle
fabrique pas elles sont fermées la
plupart donc on n'est pas encore au
moment où on va avoir une telle
explosion de croissance qu'on va manquer
de matière première fois être sérieux
c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui et c'est
pas ça qui va empêcher la halle à la
reprise la reprise économique elle va
empêcher par toutes les bêtises qu'on
avait avant
par la baisse de revenu des gens qui
n'ont pas pu travailler c'est ça qui va
bloquer la reprise c'est pas le fait de
lier 3 pidement sur sur des millions qui
manquent
faut être sérieux et là aujourd'hui on
n'a pas un problème de 2,2 d'une
explosion de la demande qui ferait que
l'offre ne pourrait pas s'ajuster
voulait va nulle part on a de la
croissance ou être sérieux deux minutes
arrêtons de parler de croissance un peu
non parce que bruno le maire ou le fmi
nous ont annoncé que cette année on
ferait 5 % de croissance
on a pas de croissance on en a pas on
fait un talon faire une croix dessus
et aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
gesticulations en disant oh là là on va
manquer de telle ou telle matière
première que ça va relancer les choses
et que ça va permettre aux entreprises
de rouvrir trouvons les d'abord posons
nous la question après nicolas meilhan
derrière cette tension et ce qui est
aussi des enjeux géopolitiques est ce
que les matières premières sont des
armes à part entière dans les rapports
de force entre différents pays oui je
suis juste avant de bien évidemment les
matières premières sont une arme une
barbe très importante et la chine là
dessus s'est positionné puisque elle a à
peu près racheter l'afrique le
moyen-orient l'afrique du sud et donc
elles contrôlent tous les pays d'où sont
extraits ces minéraux ces matières
premières elles contrôlent 80% du
raffinage du cobalt pour les voitures
électriques
donc effectivement elle est très bien
positionné pour pour pouvoir dicter sa
loi aux dépens des avants de 30
d'indépendance à 30% à 40% mais l'opep
on s'en plaignait et maintenant on est
en train de se mettre dans la gueule de
la chine et en dépendant à 80% je ne
sais pas si c'est très très malin les
gens ont oublié mais ya un an qu'est ce
qui se passait mais pas de masque et pas
de test n'est pas de gel c'était le même
problème le vrai problème au delà des
matières premières c'est qu'on est sur
une économie extrêmement globalisé où
les gens s'approvisionnent avec un
fournisseur qui fournit tout le monde
voit le jour il n'est plus capable de
tout
tout le monde les prix augmentent et
donc le véritable problème c'est qu'on a
tout à fait perdu notre souveraineté
qu'on se désindustrialiser depuis 40 ans
et qu'on a plus aucun contrôle qu'on
dépend des autres qu'on s'est dit que ça
allait être moins cher d'aller produire
le bout du monde avec un seul
fournisseur qui fournira la planète
alors oui ça coûte moins cher mais quand
il a un problème ça coûte très cher donc
la véritable aussi le véritable enjeu c
est ce qu on veut continuer de dépendre
systématiquement des autres est-ce qu'on
n'a pas envie de s'organiser un petit
peu un pour diversifier ses différents
fournisseurs de pour relocaliser
réindustrialiser une partie de cette
activité
puisqu'aujourd'hui on dépend entièrement
des autres y compris par exemple pour
nos centrales nucléaires ou les gens
pensent qu'on est souverain alors que
que l'entretien de notre parc de 60
réacteur est fait par les américains ce
qui est un peu ce qui est un peu gênant
et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup
nicolas nicolas meilhan d'avoir été
parmi nous dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
stratégie spécialisé sur les secteurs du
transport et de l'énergie est membre d
econoclaste olivier nous on continue
avec les questions cash
et on commence avec la question de
adrien olivier la démondialisation
doit-elle passer par la grande
réunissent ya lisation promu par le
forum de davos
écoutez c'est elle j'ai l'impression
qu'on s'est amusé à mettre des mots les
uns à la suite des autres mais s'en sent
bien les comprendre
non on a on a parlé dans cette dans
l'émission sur la démondialisation du
fait peut il y avait pas il n'y avait
pas vraiment démondialisation puisque
aujourd'hui les entreprises continuer et
on vient de le voir d'ailleurs continue
à avoir un seul fournisseur unique loin
parce que ça coûte moins cher et que
tant que vous aurez des pays où les
salaires sont de 100 dollars quand les
notes sont à 1500 vous aurez forcément
des entreprises qui vont continuer à
fabriquer là où les salaires sont les
moins chers donc et si vous laissez pas
en faisant des incantations pour que et
en dansant autour d'une table pour que
les les entreprises reviennent en france
que ça va se faire
elles ne reviendront que si les choses
changent ici ce qui les a fait partir
est toujours en place donc n'espérez pas
qu'elles reviennent simplement sur la
demande de monsieur le maire ou de
monsieur macron donc voilà il est trop
beaucoup trop tôt pour parler d'une
démondialisation qui ne se fera que
lorsque on aura changé les choses au
niveau mondial et au niveau français
aussi alors justement à question de
tyler 768 olivier quelles solutions pour
retenir les entreprises et les cerveaux
en france cela doit-il passer par des
réformes fiscales pour les entreprises s
envisager
que les impôts pour les entreprises
diminuent sur le long terme avec la
crise actuelle
non ça n'est pas envisageable
au contraire ça va augmenter de
c'est parce qu'une question de réforme
fiscale ou pas tout mettre sur la
fiscalité il ya un environnement qui
fait que le niveau de l'éducation baisse
donc les jeunes vont dans des
universités à l'étranger
le fait est que vous n'avez aucune
sécurité juridique en france
pourquoi parce que vous avez des lois
qui change tous les quatre matins et à
chaque mandature vous avez un lot de loi
qui arrivent pour bouleverser tout est
donc et pas que des lois fiscales qui
font que évidemment vous n'avez aucune
aucune entreprise qui n'a ni envie de
rester ni envie de revenir et donc
je vous dis c'est un c'est un changement
bien plus profond qu'il faut avoir en
france en plus vous avez perdu dans
beaucoup de secteurs le savoir faire
puisque la france s'est complètement d
industrialiser sur sur plusieurs années
donc vous avez perdu le savoir-faire
donc vous n'êtes pas prêt d'avoir des
entreprises qui reviennent et on rajoute
sans arrêt des lois qui qui font peur le
délit écologique là qu'on a mis dans la
loi fait qu' aucune entreprise n'a envie
de d'avoir ce risque sur le dos et donc
vous avez vous avez un tas de choses à
changer la fiscalité en est une mais ça
n'est pas que la fiscalité
malheureusement qui est en compte merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de votre fidélité et rendez vous
sur notre site internet pour découvrir
nos précédents numéros et puis vous
pouvez poser toutes vos questions à
olivier sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rta cachant se trouve la semaine
prochaine olivier on se quitte avec
votre dernier mot
vous l'aurez compris c'est pas dans ces
caches qu'on va mettre un petit coup de
peinture verte pour faire écolo